tenemos que factorizar menos 4 t al
cuadrado menos 12 t
9 y para empezar podemos decir hay algún
factor común para estos términos cuando
los observas bueno estos dos primeros
son divisibles entre 4 estos dos son
divisibles entre 3 pero no todos son
divisibles entre algún número común
podríamos factorizar menos 1
pero incluso si factorizar menos uno es
lo mismo que menos 1 por 4 t al cuadrado
más 12 t 9 terminas aquí con un
coeficiente que no es igual a 1 en el
término de segundo grado en el término
de la t al cuadrado así que tal vez
quieras empezar agrupando esto
inmediatamente si factorizar agrupando
funcionaría y obtendrías una respuesta
concreta pero hay algo en esta ecuación
que se te podría ocurrir y haría un poco
más fácil la solución para entender esto
hagamos un pequeño descanso aquí del
lado derecho y vamos a pensar en lo que
sucede si tomas a + b
por más ve sólo es un binomio al
cuadrado bueno tienes ahora lo cual es
al cuadrado luego tienes a por esta vez
lo que es más ave luego ve por lo que es
lo mismo que ave y luego tienes ve por
ve o ve al cuadrado si sumas estos dos
términos de enmedio te queda a al
cuadrado más 2 ave más vea al cuadrado
este es el cuadrado de un binomio ahora
esto que tenemos aquí 4 t al cuadrado
más 12 t más 9 encaja en este patrón
bueno 4 t al cuadrado es al cuadrado si
esto es al cuadrado entonces a a que es
igual si esto es a al cuadrado entonces
a sería la raíz cuadrada de esto es
igual a 2 t y si esto es b al cuadrado
si el 9 es b al cuadrado significa que
ve es igual a 3 es igual al valor
positivo de la raíz cuadrada de 9 ahora
este número que tenemos aquí en realidad
no tiene que ser igual a 3
también podría ser menos 3 podría ser
más 3 o menos 3 pero este número es 2
por ave
ese es el término del medio que nos
ocupa es igual a 2 por ave bueno si
multiplicamos 2 t por 3 obtenemos 6 t y
si multiplicamos eso por 2 obtenemos 12
t esto que tenemos aquí 12 t es igual a
2 por 2 t por 3 si es igual a 2 por ave
si esto fuera menos 3 podríamos ver si
esto es menos 12 pero funciona para el 3
positivo de modo que esto encaja en el
patrón de un cuadrado perfecto esto es
el cuadrado de un binomio entonces si
quieres factorizar esto lo que está
dentro sigue teniendo al menos uno fuera
si quieres factorizar 4 t al cuadrado
más 12 temas 9 podrías decir
inmediatamente bueno esto es igual a más
b por amas b o dos temas tres por dos
temas tres o simplemente decir esto
dos temas tres al cuadrado esto encaja
en este patrón y por supuesto no te
puedes olvidar de este menos uno que
tenemos aquí podrías haber resuelto esto
por agrupación pero este es algo que se
reconoce rápidamente este es un número
al cuadrado este es otro número al
cuadrado si tomas cada uno de esos
números que estás elevando al cuadrado y
los multiplicas entre ellos y los
multiplicas por 2 lo tienes justo aquí
por lo que es un cuadrado perfecto hasta
el próximo vídeo